welcome everybody um so things in the
russian invasion of ukraine
have not gotten any better over the
weekend and i'm going to tell you what's
been taking place and talk about
what might be the most likely
path towards de-escalation given
the personalities involved particularly
the personality of vladimir putin and
given what we have seen so far but in
order to have the conversation about how
we might get out of this we have to
understand how escalated things have
gotten and how committed to some degree
degree vladimir putin is
about um
pushing forward and
a major
sort of
i hesitate to use the term red line
because red line has had so many
particular meanings in foreign policy
over the last 15 years in the united
states but
some kind of rubicon has been crossed
over the weekend with the start of
russian attacks
on ukrainian nuclear power plants
and the concerns over
an explosive disaster proverbially and
literally have now become a significant
part of the discussion as to what's
taking place there's an associated press
report
attack on ukrainian nuclear plant
triggers worldwide alarm and why would
it not
um news from kiev
russian troops friday seized the biggest
nuclear power plant in europe after a
middle of the night attack that set it
on fire and briefly raised worldwide
fears of a catastrophe in the most
chilling turn yet in moscow's invasion
of ukraine
firefighters put out the blaze no
radiation was released russian forces
pressed on with their weak old offensive
on multiple fronts although they did not
appear to gain significant ground in
fighting friday the number of refugees
fleeing the country eclipsed 1.2 million
one of the realities that we have to
sort sort of uh accept at this point
is that
this
you know pyrrhic victory
may be too far
but
the way in which ukraine is now reacting
to the attacks
if the invasion is ultimately going to
be successful for vladimir putin and of
course i hope that it's not and i i
still believe that there's a good
possibility that it's not
putin is going to succeed
in taking some extraordinarily lam
damaged territory and what i mean by
that is when you consider the
destruction to infrastructure that the
russian troops seem totally willing to
make when it comes to nuclear power
plants roads
important government buildings etc and
when you consider the refugee
exodus from the country
and the further damaging effect that
that's going to have if there aren't
people to take care of things then it's
going to get even worse
there is a putin who seems determined
to have a quote victory no matter how
disastrous the victory is in terms of
damage to russian troops in the russian
economy and to what he's trying to steal
ukraine
in and of itself and the nuclear power
plant is just sort of like the epitome
of that because consider the damage you
could do uh by by going after that
another report uh russian forces fire
rockets at building in kharkiv that
houses a nuclear reactor this is
extraordinarily dangerous stuff and i
know some will say well david it's not
that dangerous i mean these it's still
probably going to be fine yes
when you deliberately target these types
of facilities you're willing to accept
serious and significant destruction this
article reads ukraine's national
security service have claimed that
russian forces are firing rockets at a
physics institute in kharkiv
which contains nuclear material and a
reactor
footage shows the purportedly shows the
moment a missile hits the kharkiv
institute of physics and technology
which houses the reactor no immediate
reports of damage to the nuclear
materials inside
so one very important question now
becomes
what is the off-ramp if we
let's concede a situation
where putin is unable to take ukraine
successfully in a short period of time
ima given the size of the russian forces
and the seeming determination of for
example joe biden not to send troops in
which i support to be clear given all of
that
it's not unlikely that if this did last
at the in at this scale months or longer
that at some point russia would quote
win ukraine in the sense of stealing it
but it's not coming easily and we're
going to talk about that more
and given that
what sort of circumstances would be the
most likely to get putin to say i'm i'm
going to back off now well the first and
the most important thing is putin will
back off
seemingly if he's dead or if he has some
face-saving way of backing off
given that
an attempted assassination does not
appear to be the policy of any country
that's been asked about it so far and we
will get to that because there was a big
story on that over the weekend how do
you create an off-ramp for putin where
he can sort of save face
the best kind of average of everything
that we know going on would be
you have to make it as difficult as
possible
for russia to make progress while making
it as economically damaging as possible
does that have
uh unintended consequences of hurting
the russian people of course it does
what what is already happening what's
already been done in terms of sanctions
hurts russian people as well stories of
i mean just anecdotally even just
russians outside of the country unable
to to use debit cards i mean at the
micro level it's hurting russians and at
the macro level it's going to do
significant damage as well energy prices
all these different things but it seems
as though
what you
short of sort of sending troops in
uh to ukraine and and starting to fight
a ground war of sorts you need to
continue sending support to ukrainian
troops and what are at this point
significantly volunteers as well
allow them to slow the progress of
russian troops as much as possible
make it i mean it's crazy the terms
we're talking about we're talking about
lives here make it as deadly as possible
for putin to continue pushing hurt the
economy as much as possible and pressure
putin
to
get some kind of incentive to take an
off-ramp and then give him some way to
do it while saving face now what will
that mean does that mean you've got to
give them some land i don't know and
this is where
diplomacy would presumably take over but
that seems to be the path sort
sort of really waging a war in ukraine
which right now it's not really a war
it's an invasion
that ukrainians are doing what they can
to repel understand that this isn't a
war came up because of aggressive
behavior from both sides no russia
invaded ukraine that's what started this
there has to be some path
that will suit putin's personality and i
don't know what that is but this isn't
stopping putin uh uh from from trying to
knock out the president of ukraine
zalenski and that's what i want to talk
about next